[Music]
you don't have to believe in it there's
no dogma you know even like I said it
uses iconography and symbolism from you
know things like Gnostic Christianity
and esoteric Judaism things like that
but it doesn't require you to believe in
these things the reason it uses the
symbolism is you know for example in the
part of the country that I grew up in
there are literally places where you
come to a four-way stop and there are
churches on all four corners so even if
you're completely atheist even if you're
repelled by these things they are still
part of your psyche still part of our
our culture so we on some level respond
to those things in some way that doesn't
mean we necessarily have to believe in
them for magic to work you know like I
said the people who devise these
techniques wanted to know what works why
it works how it works and how we can
make it work better you don't have to
believe in any of this any more than you
have to believe that your muscles are
gonna get bigger by going to the gym
I'll hear a lot of people say you know I
don't believe in magic and I'll think
well actually what you mean is you've
never tried magic because it doesn't
require belief if you had actually tried
these things you know invested time and
energy into attempting to do them you
would see that they actually did work
that it's not a process of belief the
way that I guess one of the things that
was so hard about Eastern traditions
like Zen was you focus almost entirely
on staying in the present moment all the
time you know that is really really hard
once you actually start trying to do
that you realize how out of control your
thoughts are you know our thoughts chase
themselves around like a dog chasing its
own tail all the time from the time we
get up until the time we go to sleep and
a lot of the Eastern traditions deal
with almost wrestling against that you
know every time you realize you're doing
it bringing yourself back to the present
moment back to the present moment over
and over and over for me I didn't get a
lot of results out of that you know I
never found myself in the present moment
more than I was whenever I started the
practices ceremonial magic on the other
hand what it does is it doesn't really
address that at all instead you're
dealing like for example on energy
circulation practice
where you're circulating Chi through
different parts of your body you're
trying to energize different energy
centers that run down through your spine
doing that as a side effect you become
more and more present and I didn't even
realize you know a lot of these
practices say for example the lesser
banishing ritual of the pentagram when
you would learn these things
traditionally the organization the order
would give you these exercises and they
would not tell you what they're gonna do
they would not tell you what they're for
they would say go practice this for a
year come back and talk to us then and
if you're interested in learning more
and going forward we'll talk about it
then whenever you came back they would
say okay well what did you experience
that's how they would know if you had
actually been practicing them or not so
I would practice these techniques the
the middle pillar the lesser banishing
ritual the pentagram and one day while I
was in prison I bent over to tie my
shoes and I realized without even trying
to do so I was in the present moment and
it was almost like an atomic bomb going
off because it was for the very first
time in my life I realized oh my god I'm
completely in the present moment of
course the second you think that it
shattered and you know you're back to
thinking or whatever but it was even
after years of Zen practice it was the
first time that I'd truly experience
that and it was due to ceremonial magic
so one of the techniques that I use you
know the analogy I used earlier about
flushing yourself out like a cup of
water this is a technique that flushes
our thoughts out you know if you have a
song going through your head over and
over or if you're reliving an argument
you had with someone a year ago if
you're you know obsessed over something
that you can't get out of your head this
technique is good for that as well as
just general meditation purposes it
doesn't have a name I usually just refer
to it as the prison cell meditation but
if you're interested I'll do that is
that okay all right you start by closing
your eyes and then you envision yourself
in a prison cell standing in the center
of a cell everything is white
the walls are white the ceiling is why
the floors are white the only thing
there is in the cell other than you on
the back wall is a slit of a window and
it's up so high that the only way that
you can reach it the only way you can
see out of it is by gripping the window
ledge high above your head and hoisting
yourself up by sheer brute physical
upper-body strength almost like you're
doing a pull-up or a chin-up so you want
to bring as much tactile sensation to
the visualization as you possibly can
you want to feel it
as much as you can so picture yourself
walking to the back of this wall
pressing yourself against it reaching up
with your hands and gripping the edge of
that window seal with your fingertips
try to feel what the back wall of that
prison cell would feel like pressed
against the side of your face pressed
against your torso feel the coldness of
it the grittiness of it and as you start
to lift yourself up off the floor using
just your arms try to feel what that
would actually feel like feel the
muscles in your shoulders feel the
muscles in your chest and your abdomen
firing tensing as you're pulling
yourself up try to feel what the wall
would feel like as you scrape against it
lifting yourself slowly by sheer
strength as your eyes crestock over the
rim of the window white light burst
through the window floods through the
window and obliterates everything the
cell you everything until there's only
white light remaining do it again press
yourself against the back of the wall
reach up with both hands and grip the
edge of the windowsill feel the muscles
in your chest in your abdomen and your
shoulders tensing as you start to lift
yourself up feel the wall scrape against
the front of your thighs against the
side of your face as you hoist yourself
until your eyes go over the edge of the
window frame and then white light comes
flooding in through the window
obliterating everything you the cell
until there is only white light once
more feel yourself pressed against the
wall raise your arms
hook your fingertips over the window
ledge begin to raise yourself slowly up
by sheer strength
feeling the muscles in your shoulders
your chest your torso
straining as you lift your bodyweight
feel the wall of the prison sail as you
scrub against it and as your eyes go
over the edge of the window frame white
light comes flooding in obliterating
everything and this is one of those
things you can do for as long as you
have time you can do it five times you
can do it 10 times the longer you do it
the more effective it is and it gives
you something to work with you know in
your visualization instead of just
trying to stay in the present moment
which is really really hard
[Music]